hey what's up everybody i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
and today is october
21st we're going to be doing a live q a
and of course there is chat happening
right now at
reubenreport.locals.com which you can do
over on the desktop if you're old school
or you can download our ios or android
app
and play along uh the reason i have a
sort of half smile on my face is because
funny things happen in this studio right
before uh the show starts i had to ask
my crack producer michael if rachel
levine has actually had her penis
chopped off i wanted to know the full
information before we get to the q a i
normally don't look at the questions i
take like a the quickest glance right
before we start i saw the first one was
about rachel levine our new four-star
general health secretary trans first
female something and i just wanted to
know like did she go all the way i just
wanted to know
uh anyway before we get to that and it
seems unknown thank you for doing the
research on that i don't even want to
know what you had to google to not
figure that out
but before we get to any of that uh you
know this kamala harris lady this is
this woman who was polling at zero in
her own party primary when she was
running for president she dropped out
very early after everyone thought she
could possibly actually be the
presidential candidate for the democrats
pulled at zero nobody liked her she has
this psychotic cackle very inauthentic
woman you may have seen her on something
probably a news channel or saying anyway
it was her birthday yesterday and this
elderly confused gentleman joe biden
who's not really sure what he's doing uh
well he's he
surprised her uh in her office and take
a look at this surely not scripted very
human moment
thank you oh look at that gordon
[Music]
this is my favorite
got it thank you oh i'm gonna hang this
up with grape pride thank you mr
president
[Music]
this is my favorite
thank you mr president
god these people they're not humans i
don't know what they are but they have
had their souls sucked out of them there
is nothing human or real about these
people later we could have showed you
video on this too you might have seen it
already online but later in the day they
had a surprise party for kamala kamala
whatever her name is she walks into the
room and it's such a surprise that when
she walks into the room she yells
surprise then she kisses her husband
while they're both wearing masks also
there's absolutely no reason for joe
biden to be wearing a mask there's no
reason for her to be wearing masks it's
all theater the show
must go on anyway happy birthday kamala
you're doing a hell of a job despite
everything crumbling right in front of
you your your cackling laugh has uh
you know given us great joy over here uh
just a reminder guys join our live chat
play around with people get comments
directly to me as we're doing this i've
also been informed that we're probably
going to be demonetized today because i
said chopping off the penis
you know and now i just said it again so
now
i have sealed my fate hello youtubers
uh all right here we go q a all
submitted at
reubenreport.locals.com uh shelly says
i've seen that rachel levine has been
made a four-star admiral i'm wondering
what she did to earn it has she ever
been in the military and is this a
regular habit of our government
as a military brat and wife and mother
of military members i'm really upset
that rank is given out with having to
earn it well what do you mean she didn't
earn it she used to be a man and now
she's a check possibly chopped off her
nuts you gotta give her four stars do
they do five stars
can we can you get a bonus star going i
mean
i have no idea i don't think she's
qualified like
it has nothing to do with it it's the
same thing with buddha judge becoming
transportation secretary they just want
these token people i i don't even care
if she's a good person a decent person i
don't even care if she's qualified i
suspect she's probably not right because
if you have a whole pool of people there
are probably other deserving people and
by the way our
surgeon general tweeted out
congratulations to the first female
four-star general blah blah blah
whatever it is and it's like no you can
say transgender she is transgender
nobody's doubting that
if that's the way that rachel levine
wants to live so be it and i'll even use
her pronouns okay that's actually all
fine with me uh personally um but when
the surgeon general doesn't know the
difference between male and female you
think we have a problem so no she didn't
earn it it's like these are this is what
they do you're gay you get this you're
trans you get this you're black you get
this
in the name of diversity intolerance of
course
i won't say chopped off penis again now
i've said it three times
jacob says is sake an actual psychopath
or is she due for a mental breakdown any
day now no reasonable person could get
up there and lie about everything day in
and day out this is a good question
because you have to think about these
people as human beings not just like
these creatures that live in your
television and computer box like she is
a person i think she has kids like she
wakes up in the morning i i suspect she
thinks she's probably doing good but the
question is really does she know she's
lying and then what does that sort of do
to the soul now
i'm gonna go on a limb here and say that
she doesn't fully know she's lying that
the progressive woke groupthink thing
it is so all-encompassing it's so
ubiquitous in society and it's so
insular and she's so surrounded herself
with swamp creatures and politics people
and media people that everyone is lying
all the time like there's this constant
sort of lie that everybody's going
around and remember i talk to you guys
about laundering lies that politicians
lie about things then it gets lied about
in the way the mean mainstream media
covers it and that big tech fuels those
lies depending on what they let trend
and how they sort of frame the story and
all that
partly i think they're all sort of doing
it without quite knowing it like they
really in their heart of hearts think
they're fighting white supremacists they
think they're the good guys all of that
stuff but at another level
i think she absolutely does know it she
knows that things are not going well
right now when she has to get up there
and lie about supply chains
and as we showed yesterday when she has
to get up there and when they say to her
uh peter ducey says to her you know
we're shipping people immigrants across
america in the middle of the night and
she's like 4 30 a.m not middle of the
night like this sort of
you know like bait and switch with
language and whether it's at whether 4
30 of the night at night is at night or
early in the morning as she said like
it's all just nonsense they lie about
everything and you can actually see it
in her face she looks absolutely
miserable and you know jordan peterson
talks about this a lot when you're when
you're telling the truth and you're
you're being honest and you're being
what you're supposed to be you can
actually see it in people's faces you
really can see it but over time as the
lies sort of stick with you and you know
you're not doing good for whatever
reason that is it starts the face
becomes drawn and gaunt and pained and
all of those things i'm feeling it right
now just even thinking i was putting
myself in her body for a moment that um
that was weird now we're definitely
demonetized again jesus
um can you say jesus i'm not even sure
if you could say jesus anymore um anyway
i i so i don't know it's a little bit of
like i want to give them a little bit of
a leash and then on another hand it's
like no if you just go up and lie every
day if you know people are crossing our
borders and you pretend that there's no
crisis if you lie about supply chains if
you tell us 3.5 trillion is zero if you
lie
about the january sixth insurrection all
of the [ __ ] if you just lie about it
over and over i have to at some point
impune your motives which is not with my
original intent so saki she knows she
absolutely knows
and what do we do with that like what do
we do with that they they lie about
every single thing every single thing uh
henry says what are some new additions
to locals that you're going to implement
in the near future uh
henry i can't say too much but let's
just say something big is happening and
i should have an update for you in the
next day or two
all right henry there you go that's all
i can say about that right now
mikkelt says what happened with herd
immunity does it still matter
no it doesn't matter it's a miracle we
were told two weeks to flatten the curve
then we just stopped talking about that
right like nobody would ever bring up
the curve again right like it's just
we're just done with the curve and then
herd immunity this idea that enough of
us would catch covid that it would work
through the system we would have natural
antibodies young people would be okay a
certain amount of people would get sick
and live a certain amount of people
would get sick and not live but that the
herd the group of us the collective us
uh would actually be okay without having
to immunize
98 of people which is what joe biden
wants right now which i'm pretty sure
that would leave about five million
unvaccinated people in the united states
and i'm pretty sure that those people
would be treated horribly and probably
sent to camps and not be allowed to work
and everything else
the reason we don't talk about herd
immunity anymore is because this is not
about a virus anymore kovid the covid
panic and hysteria is not about covid
the virus everyone at this point two
years in has done what they think is
right everyone has done it everyone has
done it that's just the truth um
it is now about
making
at least for for the government people
and the people pushing all this nonsense
it's about just breaking people can we
absolutely break people
can we force people to inject themselves
with stuff whether they want to or not
can we make them do it every few months
can we lie to them and then make sure
that they forget the lies so that we can
keep dragging them into the slow descent
to hell
can we just confuse what science
actually is right like can we confuse
that we used to talk about hurting
immunity but we don't even talk about it
anymore it's like why don't we because
they obviously want everyone to be
immunized now i don't even think that
means that they're trying to immunize
everybody to kill everybody like i'm not
going down that conspiracy hole uh but
by the way i think you should be allowed
to go down whatever conspiracy hole you
want to talk about it without being
punished by the place you work or or
youtube or the government
um but partly it's just like they want
to they want to institute just a system
that everyone will be broken remember
when you're a kid and you're told
stand up for what you believe in
remember that
why don't we talk about that anymore why
does nobody talk about that why does no
one in the government old joe
kamala
saki why don't any of these people ever
get up there fouchy and say you know boy
we we do want everybody to get
vaccinated and we wish people would and
but at the same time we do understand
personal choice or we do understand that
you know maybe we've made some mistakes
along the way or we do understand that
actually keeping kids in masks doesn't
really make sense and we do understand
that there's an awful lot of videos of
us
uh you know basically going against our
edicts as we demand that you do it that
we've kind of screwed up some of this
stuff but there's never any self
reflection this is what the left has
done so well
these last couple years as they've
ruined so much of what's great about
america they never look back they never
look back that's why i have to say you
kind of have to admire it it doesn't
mean you i don't want to be that way i
like self-reflection i think we have to
be much better than them but it's harder
to be better
it's not harder to be better than them
it's harder as a person to be a better
person right like that's the challenge
in life to be a better person these
people
never
stop they never go boy
you know maybe maybe calling everyone
racist was a bad idea i was even
thinking about it on on the race front
it's like is after all of this social
justice stuff is america more or less
racist right now let's say in the last
five years i would say america probably
is more racist because we weren't racist
five years ago we really weren't and now
they've hyper-racialized everything so
the lefties are all racists they're just
new school races and i suspect they're
breeding some racists on the right
otherwise you know people who otherwise
would not have been racist people who
didn't look at everything through a
racial lens but you know who maybe are
just white and regular people who just
want to go about their lives who are
sick of being called the worst things in
the world so they start kind of becoming
racist does that seem possible i i
suspect
so so it is our work to be better than
these people and and actually the silver
lining is they're not that good so it
ain't that hard
laurie not lightfoot says we know there
are theories that the obama third uh the
obama third term being one but who do
you suspect is actually behind this
truly evil agenda that's seeking to tear
america apart from within
it seems to me this is the obama third
term that they could only get a certain
amount of it done that obama
and and just his crew remember there's
that video we need to show it again
let's let's show it again uh maybe
tomorrow or certainly next week the
obama interview where he says you know
boy the best thing for me would be to
have my two terms as president and then
basically uh be able to do everything
from behind the scenes i'm slightly
paraphrasing him but that's pretty much
what he said he's getting that right now
i think all of the worst progressive
leftist marxist ideas are being
pushed through
and again this is where i would give a
very strong
you guys were seriously wrong to my good
decent liberal friends and even the last
few somewhat sane liberals whoever they
are this i'm talking about the the you
know bill maher
uh barry y sam harris crew it's like you
guys have to admit that you voted all
this in and you supported all of this
stuff i know i know you don't want to
admit it this would go for stephen
pinker jonathan hate nick christopher a
lot of people who i've had on the show
this is not an attack on them personally
but if you were a democrat
who said
oh
tru i don't like trump biden will be the
thing that will stop the left it was so
obvious that it wasn't going to happen
and you you have to acknowledge that you
just sit there with that and go boy
things are way worse you know what i
mean it's like there would not be
shortages right now if donald trump was
president there wouldn't be i'm pretty
sure donald trump could have got the
supply chain going i'm pretty sure we
would be out of a lot of the covid
madness because the covet madness is
being fabricated by this government that
wants to control you and you may not
have liked donald trump but he never
wanted this kind of control over your
life which by the way
is why donald trump kept kicking it all
back to the states and if i'm not
mistaken they've just released some new
state uh covet update stuff and
florida's at the lowest levels right now
in the entire country um so
so who is it really like it's it's obama
i i think it's partly that china has
infected a lot of the swamp creatures
like china's gotta be loving this right
now like if you were an
enemy of america or let's say you wanted
to be the great superpower
russia china i think more likely china
it's like wouldn't you be thrilled
watching america like just slowly commit
harry carrie we're just slowly pushing
the knife into our own uh
stomach you know and they're just
watching us do it and we're fighting
about gender pronouns while the castle
is burning down so i don't know is it
obama is it china is it some mix of all
that is it is it a group of sort of
technocrats you know just like the big
tech oligarchs who just love all the
power they have over all of us
it's some version of all of that
sally says what media outlets if any
should we trust you know this is very
difficult this is where i always say
it's like you got to try to find people
who you basically trust right so if you
watch this show you basically trust me
it doesn't mean i'm gonna get everything
right occasionally i make mistakes you
know the other day it was brought to my
attention that because i don't do any of
this on a script that's the thing i'm
just i'm just talking to you guys for a
half hour right i have a note like oh
this is the next story that sort of
thing but occasionally i make a mistake
i uh actually confused i think i said
that george washington um
stepped down after the civil war
obviously i met the revolutionary war
i uh actually commented in the youtube
comment section on it after because i
realized they made a mistake but like
the point is that we all make mistakes
like little directional mistakes or we
make you know a chronological error that
sort of thing um but like i think you
guys that watch me have a basic sense
that i'm trying
to bring some level of sanity and
honesty to some of this right um it's
you got to figure out who who is doing
that for you look a couple things that i
think are pretty decent right now i
think the blaze is doing some really
nice work obviously it's somewhat
right-leaning right glenn beck my good
friend obviously is somewhat
right-leaning but they i think do pretty
good honest work the daily wire i think
does pretty good honest work i think the
new york post
does pretty good honest work the epic
times even has been doing some nice
stuff so like there are
some organizations but i would say just
kind of follow a couple people and then
it's not that they're gonna predict
everything right right like i honestly
thought that donald trump was going to
win the election this year now i don't
want to say that there was any sort of
high chance or anything because we've
already been demonetized eight times
today
but like all right so i got that wrong
but i think the issues that i talk about
on a day-to-day basis are the right
issues i think they're the the
principles that i talk about are the
right principles for you to live a free
life for me to live a free life um and
and by the way honest bias is okay i'm
not pretending that i'm a journalist so
that's the fundamental difference when
you turn on cnn don lemon he says it
often says that he's a journalist now
don lemon's not a journalist he's not
out on the field anywhere he puts on a
suit he sits in a studio and he pretends
to not be a democrat operative and by
the way this is the same thing for chris
cuomo i would say a slightly lesser
extent to anderson cooper not that
anyone's watching these shows anymore
but the point is they're pretending to
be unbiased journalists i'm telling you
i have a bias my bias is towards freedom
my bias is towards limited government my
bias is towards you right like you can
figure it out you don't need these
[ __ ] idiots in washington
now we're definitely if i make it
through the show today it'll be a
miracle um i think you know how to live
your life that's the point uh joe says
yesterday a top nih official lawrence
tabik admitted in a letter to james
comer who's a republican from kentucky
that the nih did in fact fund gain of
function research in wuhan this
contradicts congressional testimony of
one doctor fascinating
dr fauci any thoughts yes so this is
super interesting so you may remember we
played clips of it here and i've
interviewed rand paul about it that when
there was a congressional hearing a
couple months back uh rand paul who is a
doctor himself by the way asked well he
basically told fouchy he said we know
that the nih which you're in charge of
has been funding this gain of function
research at a lab in wuhan in this in
essence coming up with new viruses
that's what gain of function is okay and
there's reasons to do it
at least scientifically there's reasons
to do it you would prefer it not leak
out of a lab okay fouchy attacked rand
paul just like completely indignant well
now it is coming out that it actually is
true now fauci also said that under oath
now will fouchy get into any trouble no
because the swamp protects itself that's
what the swamp does you may remember
james clapper he was the head of the
c.i.a years ago when they asked him does
the nsa spy on american citizens and
there's that beautiful moment where he
scratches the very top of his head and
he says not wittingly
and you may remember the episode of
seinfeld where jerry is telling elaine
about when you're lying and when you
make a small lie you touch here in a
medium lie you touch your face here and
a big lie you scratch the top of your
head so he lied under oath
nothing happened to him he's actually
you're not going to believe this guys
james comey is a cnn contributor now so
there you go you fell up with these
people uh so i suspect the same thing
will happen with fouchy it does not
matter if fouchy lies under oath it
doesn't matter if these people get
everything wrong it doesn't matter how
many people die under their watch
they have created
the perfect system and again this is why
you have to admire it if they if it's
going well with kovid they they and
their media cohorts believe it's because
of all of their restrictions if when
things get better it's because of the
lockdowns it's because of the masks it's
because of the vaccines when things get
get worse ah it's because of those
unvaccinated racist white supremacist
it's because of trump and the january
6th insurrection when people are out
there protesting justice without masks
that's good because now we'll get hurt
immunity they were literally saying that
in the old days when we used to talk
about herd immunity you look back to
about eight nine months ago before uh
biden was president when they were
protesting social justice and trump was
president oh we'll get hurt immunity
people young people will be out there
they'll get antibodies it'll be great
then when trump has a rally these are
super spreader events everyone's gonna
die
you gotta admire the evil fred says
about the future of mandates given
more data about the lack of efficacy and
leakiness of the vaccines what do you
think will they be able to keep this up
as more and more information comes in
from around the world
so basically what you're asking is is
sort of from a compilation video we
played a couple days ago where at the
beginning we were told the vaccines were
a hundred percent effective then it
started slowly working its way through
the media then it was 91 then it was 84
then it was 69 now we're demonetized
again then it was 43
and now it's like okay now you have to
get a booster shot just in the last day
or so they're now saying they're looking
into i think the cdc is looking into
whether you can mix booster shots
meaning if you got the pfizer
first two shots if you were to get a
moderna or johnson and johnson booster
could you mix those and it's like well
i i don't know the science behind that
i'm not going to pretend that i do but
if you didn't want people to know if
they were having weird reactions to
things wouldn't you want them to be
mixing things wouldn't that be sort of
how it works that might be all right
guys last question because i'm doing
jesse kelly's show in just a minute so
we got a wrap on time today james says
i'm getting married in a week any advice
from your personal experience wow i like
the personal ones let's do more personal
ones you're getting married week well
first off congratulations
and uh your 2b wife has picked a fine
man because you're part of the reuben
report community um you know what
it's a frank sinatra song just get a
kick
out of the person you're with i get no
kick from champagne
but i get a kick out of you right like
that's the point like when you're with
the person you love
like and you're building a good life
together like make sure to get a kick
out of them like the fact that i could
still make david laugh 11 years later
the fact that he can make me laugh we
can still surprise each other sometimes
you know we like to surprise each other
with with dinners or whatever it might
be like
just get a kick out of that person
randomly throw on some disco music dance
around the house do it even if you don't
like to dance just
yeah just that's it that that's the way
i see it like if you just just want to
be on that adventure with that person
and then life can be a great adventure
together and you just never know what
will happen next there you go
in closing guys join us at
reubenreport.locals.com there is some
major stuff i'm going to announce and
i'm going to announce it on locals first
it's coming it's coming it's coming
trust me i want to tell you i just need
like a day or so
and tomorrow we're doing an all
female
and all penis-less
guest battle
the channel has been blown up uh deborah
soh alicia krauss jebediah byla former
co-host of the view and we're going to
talk about kids and and psychological
trauma throughout this and and how the
just pushing vaccines on everybody and
parents that are trying to push kids to
be trans and just like all the crazy
stuff we're going to do all that
tomorrow anyway i got a crazy day today
so i gotta get going hope you enjoy the
show and i'll see you tomorrow bye